only four days ago
shinzo abe became japan's
longest-serving prime minister
i needed to fight against the disease
and to receive treatment
i wasn't really in the best of health
and i still had to make
important political decisions i couldn't
make any mistakes
the public supported me and i couldn't
betray their confidence
i can't do this and so i've decided
not to continue as prime minister
mr albert's resignation was not entirely
a bolt from the blue
he's lived with his chronic illness
ulcerative colitis for a long time
and he was due to stand down at the end
of his term in september next year
but it comes at a crucial moment for
japan
the country is not only dealing with
clovid it's working hard
to make sure the delayed 2020 olympics
can go ahead in tokyo next summer
i really struggled to make this decision
there's been a downward trend in the
number of infections since july
and going into the winter it's necessary
that new measures are taken
therefore new leadership is needed to
address this challenge
and this is the only time when the
change in leadership should happen
mr albe first became prime minister back
in 2006
but resigned after a year because of his
health
the prime minister's office may as well
have had a revolving door back then
japan had 13 prime ministers in 19 years
before mr abe returned in 2012.
he then bucked that trend his long
tenure
meant he could address a drifting
japanese economy with a program of
reform that borrowed his name
urbanomics
i will increase jobs and incomes
at home he also pursued controversial
more nationalistic policies
increasing defense spending and seeking
to overhaul japan's pacifist
constitution
he also visited the yakusuni shrine a
memorial to japan's war dead
that includes convicted war criminals
that prompted outrage in other asian
countries
especially china but mr albe handled
relations with other countries well
in his globe-trotting diplomacy
he seemed to know just how to get along
with other leaders
japan's ancient traditions still endure
now the question is whether mr abe's
legacy well
[Music]
whether urbanomics can continue without
abe
he has no clear successor that revolving
prime ministerial door
might start spinning again tom cheshire
sky news